green flags
the green flags in women
what better quality women look like okay
so
you can only identify these things once
you've been run through the grinder in
every way to sunday sort of thing so pay
attention okay
some of these green flags by the way are
are going to be the polar opposite of
the red flags like i talk about why you
want to stay away from women with daddy
issues in the book and why that's a
problem a green flag is you want a woman
that's got a good relationship with her
father if her father's around
and she has a relationship with him is
it a good one does she
you know does she communicate with a guy
on a regular basis do they hang out do
they have dinner together every once in
a while does she speak highly of him
does she speak highly of men in general
would be another green flag right does
she like men does she embrace
masculinity okay these are all tied into
does she have a good relationship with
her old man he's a good guy too right
you know what does a family look like if
and you know actually before i continue
i should probably preface with a few
things just to make it clear
if
you want to be in a in a position
to look for green flags
and avoid toxic women and stay away from
the red flags you've got to do work on
yourself first okay like you have to be
a man worthy of seeking out these better
qualities in women and staying away from
the toxic qualities i.e the 20 red flags
in that free chapter that i talk about
over there
because you're not going to be in a good
position to do that i mean if you're
broke fat you don't have style you've
got terrible neck beard style going on
or something crazy like that you got to
understand guys you got to get yourself
sorted before you're going to be in a
position to oh look there's an ice cream
flag over there i think i want to you
know get with her there's a there's
quite a few here that i'm going to go
through but you get the idea do the work
on yourself first if you're and i talk
about in the book when you shouldn't and
should date so you can get clear in
those details it's available on amazon
get it but
i'm not going to talk about that in
today's show so let's get back into
these green flags
the old man good relationship we talked
about uh has an affinity towards strong
masculinity she likes men she's got a
good relationship with her father
that sort of thing this is an important
thing because you're a dude and i'm
assuming that you're a dude of some you
know level of competence and skills and
you got your life together and you got
you act together and you're
more of a top shelf guy
uh leaning towards like a one percent
sort of man
she has to have a good relationship with
that right um i'm i'm coming at many of
these assumptions from my own experience
so take it with a grain of salt some of
these that i talk talk about over here
you may or may not be interested in you
may not even be in a position to seek
them you know depending on what your
personal lifestyle choices have been
the next one i got is
if you get sick does she take care of
you this is this is really important
because your boys aren't going to do it
you know your brothers aren't gonna do
it uh you know friends of yours they're
not gonna take care of you if you get
sick a green flag and a woman is if she
sees that you're not doing well
she doesn't go off in the other
direction to the nightclub partying with
her girlfriends and hanging out with
them
all night she's got your back she'll go
out to the drugstore and pick up what
you need if there's certain things that
need to get dealt with uh that your boys
or your friends probably wouldn't deal
with just because the nature of you know
what's going on in your illness
a good woman a woman with a clear and
concise green flag takes care of a dude
if he's sick
she doesn't run off on him she doesn't
go ignore him
she doesn't
abandon him in any sense whatsoever now
you're not going to be in a position
to be able to ask her to help you out
and take care of you if you're not a guy
worthy of that again if you're broke fat
boring uh incompetent uh
insignificant all those things chances
are you're not in a position to say hey
babe you know i'm not feeling so good
you want to come on over and take care
of me this is what's going on in my life
she's gonna be like no that's okay i'm
gonna go over here and hang out with
betsy that's what's going to end up
happening so
if you're a top shelf guy
and she's not taking care of you red
flag get rid of her top shelf guy and
something goes sideways in your life and
you need looking after for a short
period of time that's a green flag
another one
another green flag is she stays away
from news drama
cable tv
bachelorette type of shows bachelor
shows all that crap
if she doesn't have cable
that's a good check that's you know it's
a green flag if she's not sitting around
watching news all day or cnn or any of
that nonsense that's a green flag if
she's not constantly chasing
um drama on podcast platforms like one
podcast that i would say is a red flag
is if you have her paying attention to
like silly shows like call her daddy or
what's that one with that uh porn star
um
the two girls in the kitchen even though
they're doing nothing in the kitchen
that's related to making food they're
just sitting there yammering away stuff
like that anything that's news drama
gossip bachelorette type of stuff
red flag stay away from that she doesn't
consume that that's a good thing same
thing with the phone you know if she's
on her phone a lot she's consuming a lot
of content she's consuming a lot of
social media um that's a big red flag
it's not a good use of her time there's
far far better things that could be done
you know exactly what i'm talking about
i shouldn't have to spend too much time
on that
again some of these i'm gonna assume
that you guys have enough common sense
to you know understand exactly what i'm
talking about i shouldn't have to spell
out every single line for you
um
so we talked about that let's go to
generally positive and cheery about life
and work
so i've dated
i've dated a couple women that all they
do is they just
[ __ ] and whine and complain about
people at work
i remember this one girl she would
constantly talk about this character at
her at her office she used to call her
ghetto [ __ ] and it's like oh you
wouldn't believe what ghetto [ __ ] did
at work today and blah blah blah it's
like all i got was an earful for like 20
25 minutes every day about ghetto [ __ ]
and i was like that is quite enough and
then there was another one
different girl complaining all the time
about the part-timer
all right there's another earful every
single day about what this idiot would
do in the office and how you had to
listen to all the negativity
generally speaking a green flag and a
woman is she's generally positive and
she's cheery about life and work she's
not coming coming at you all the time
with her bull crap about characters in
the office with their nicknames
kiddo [ __ ] and part-timer you get the
idea you know what i'm saying be very
very careful with that
you you also want to look for a woman
that's got some purpose in life okay
uh but she isn't a boss girl so
you know i had this conversation uh i
think it was about a week ago week ago
with one of the newer guys in my uh
group
and um you know he was like oh yeah you
know i like these kinds of girls like
okay so what kind of girl do you like
he's like oh you know i like these boss
girls and
all the
all the generals you know basically sat
back and like all right who wants to
take this one first right
these these
these women with purpose at boss girl
level they're a nightmare they're
insufferable they're they're always
going to be
a real pain in your butt now again these
are all women that you can have
interactions with you can have
you know short-term fwb sorts of
relationships you can spin them as
plates but what i'm saying here is
because the question that i got was what
do the green flags look like how do i
identify better quality woman rich okay
this is what we're talking about so
we're talking about stuff that you know
you might want to look for like positive
traits if you wanted to invite her into
your life when she brings up the talk
you don't you don't say hey look you
know let's be boyfriend girlfriend let
her bring up the talk like where do we
stand and that's when you can decide
from that but these are the green flags
that i'm telling you guys to look for so
that should make sense to you again
she's got some purpose in life but she's
not a boss girl like she's got something
going on you know she's not basic if you
know what i'm saying so like there's
something happening there
uh the next one after that i took note
of is she takes ownership for her
choices in life
why is this important why is this a
green flag because accountability and
women are two words that don't usually
go together very often okay
um you see it a lot on a lot of the
social platforms it's always somebody
else's fault the government the
patriarchy my boss my husband my
ex-husband my ex-boyfriend my boyfriend
it's it's it's always somebody out there
that's doing them wrong
and
a solid green flag in a woman is
somebody is a woman specifically that
takes ownership for her choices in life
she makes some bad choices you know what
that was that was stupid of me i'm not
going to do that again and if they need
help with something then they seek help
you know they'll go looking for answers
if they need a therapist for something
then they talk to a therapist that's you
know there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that
what's wrong with that is if she's
talking to multiple therapists and you
see your medicine cabinet and there's
rows and rows of prescription bottles of
all kinds of you know happy pills in
there if you know what i'm saying that's
a little bit offside but you want
somebody that's going to take ownership
for their choices it should be obvious
to you okay i shouldn't have to clarify
that one too too much next one i got is
and you know this is kind of again an
opposite towards a red flag is um you
want to make sure that she doesn't have
a large notch count okay
notch count ties into being alpha
widowed uh well let's talk about elf
being being awful widow for a moment
here if she's constantly
running her mouth about some guy from
her past
how good or how bad he was it doesn't
matter but if she doesn't shut up about
some guy
from her past
or tries to compare you to a guy from
her past um
another one would be comparing you like
comparing your worst to one of her
girlfriend's best okay that's kind of a
red flag
we're talking about green ones right now
but we're going to go back and forth and
explain why that one's important
um let's say you're a top shelf guy you
know you got your life together you make
bank drive a nice car your house is paid
off you got loads of money lots of
investments assets blah blah blah that
sort of stuff and you're the kind of guy
that you know leaves your socks on the
floor right
if she's constantly chirping you about
your socks being on the floor or why
can't you put the
white socks on the white hamper and the
dark socks and the dark hamper and then
she starts comparing you to
i don't know billy who is uh you know
nancy's husband or boyfriend or whatever
well he doesn't leave his socks on the
floor and he picks them up and he puts
them in the hamper
all right she's chirping you now what
does billy do you know is he a garbage
collector is he uh is he a janitor at
the gym like what does he do right like
what what's the guy all about because if
she's comparing your worst which is
leaving socks on the floor to her
girlfriend's best which is a guy that
picks up his socks but he's got nothing
else going on if you see what i'm
getting at here right like you want to
pay attention to that let me just go
back to the alpha widow thing if if
she's going to always talk about some
guy from her past guy that she was with
and guy that she was intimate with and
she can't get him out of her head she's
never going to be able to look at you as
her best you're never going to get her
best you know at the end of the day so
you want to stay away from those that
have been alpha widowed that that
haven't gotten over
dudes from their past if it's dudes it's
a big problem if it's a dude it's still
a problem if there's nothing there
that's a green flag right
um next one she's pleasant and doesn't
nag you persistently
do i need to explain that one
you know a green flag and a woman is
you kind of lose track of time when you
hang out together you laugh a lot she
laughs at your jokes you know you have a
good time sort of thing you have some
dialogue and some banter okay
but
you know if all you're listening to is
why can't you do this and you're driving
me crazy for that and da da da
if all you're listening to is unpleasant
dialogue and nagging it's a red flag i
mean why would you want to invite that
in your life you want somebody that's
pleasant and doesn't nag you
persistently you see what i'm saying
um next one
you want a woman that's going to
encourage and support your purpose
why is that important because you're a
dude
you know guys need to chase excellence
you have to have something going on in
your world world something anything
you know the more significant the more
important it is the more impact that it
has in your lives and those of others
the better it is for you
and if she's going to encourage and
support you being on your grind that's a
good thing if she's going to get in the
way of that it's a bad thing it's a red
flag right so you want you want to see
an obvious sign
that she's not getting in the way that
so i.e um
let's say that you host events or you
have to go to events
and there's certain days of the week
that that has to happen on let's say
that uh it ends up falling on a day that
you would normally see this uh lady
um
and then she's like okay cool no problem
i'll just you know i'll meet you
afterwards you know i'll seat your house
or uh you know just come over to my
place when you're done that's a green
flag you know that's that's a good sign
but if she's gonna chirp you like
wednesday nights are our nights and then
you can't why'd you do that
that's that's red flag straight up right
so look for somebody that's going to
support and encourage your purpose
whatever your grind happens to be
um oh i didn't talk about the notch
count with the alpha widow part so the
notch count is really important um i
talk about it in the red flag chapter in
my book again you can get that over here
there's a few different places in the
book why i define why that's important
but a woman can't form a healthy pair
bond to a guy
if she's run through a bunch of guys
it's as simple as that you don't want to
like at any conflict or any corner like
if she's been through 50 60 100 guys
i don't even care
you know any number
that is that is more than one is is
going to complicate more and more it's
just you know as the number gets bigger
the worse it gets 50 is obviously worse
than 10 10 is obviously worse than two
you get the you know you get the idea
but if there's if there's something
going on
and she's not digging it she's gonna
bounce quicker if she's used to bouncing
right she's been through a bunch of guys
i'm out leave my crap on the front porch
i'm gonna pick it up i'm out of here you
know what this you know what the lyrics
sound and look like right so you want a
woman that's got a low notch count so
that she's going to enter your frame and
compliment your life and not chirp you
and nag you persistently and be
unpleasant all those sorts of things a
woman with a lower notch count is more
likely
to be a compliment to your life if you
know what i'm saying all right
um
she's active and she exercises i mean a
lot of these that i'm talking about here
um are things that i think about you
know if
she's dormant and sits around all day
like this and she's basically you know
made out of like jello
and it happens with bigger women it also
happens with smaller women you know you
don't have to be obese to have horrible
body composition if you know what i'm
saying so a woman that's active in
exercises should be important it matters
to me it's up to you it doesn't matter
to you who cares but i look at it as a
green flag right because i like to do
[ __ ]
um she's got culinary skills
this is important i like to eat i don't
necessarily like to prepare meals all
the time
i offer things that women don't offer
right
do i need to list them all she better
show up with some culinary skills right
because if she doesn't have them
what does she have to offer you know
there's a
there's an old line that uh
that an old friend of mine used to say
and he used to say that a woman's got a
very simple job
if your stomach's full she's got to keep
your balls empty it's as simple as that
and you know you can decide for yourself
whether or not you think that's right or
wrong or off-site doesn't matter to me
but to me a green flag is a woman that
knows how to cook most women today they
don't know how to cook or they have
terrible culinary skills all that they
know how to do is order ubereats or they
have one dish that they can make it's
very basic so i look for a woman that's
got culinary skills she knows how to
cook she makes healthy meals they're
good she knows what she's doing that's
what i'm talking about i think i think
that's important
personally i wouldn't i wouldn't bypass
it i think too many guys just like ah
it's okay i'm just gonna ignore that we
can just order food or i'm a good shelf
there's some guys out there that like to
cook i've got a few close friends of
mine um a couple guys i know that that
that have amazing culinary skills and
they just like to cook that's fine me
that's not me so you know you can you
can customize these for you as you go
but
it's uh it's a non-negotiable as far as
i'm concerned
um she's tidy and cleans up unprompted
and continues doing so unprompted
right
um give you an example so
if your chick is uh she makes your bed
in the morning let's say okay
uh you get up you have your coffee she
gets up does her thing have her shower
and you go upstairs later on you notice
the bed's been made that's good very
nice you know
i appreciate that's very kind but if
that starts to lack gets lots of days
you know like i don't know maybe she's
got something going on she's you know
she's in a little bit of a huff or a
hissy with you and she doesn't make the
bed that's unacceptable you want to see
consistent behavior you want it you want
to know that you can rely on her because
if you're going to invite her into your
life over a longer term basis you need
to know that she's reliable and
consistent and doesn't waver from from
positive behaviors from from green flag
type of behaviors and small things like
that i mean you got to hold them
accountable it's like um hold on a
second you know
one of the reasons why i selected you
and invited you into my life is because
you were doing these things you know
just insert whatever reason you know
you're making my bed in the morning now
all of a sudden you don't do that
anymore well
what's up with that right you hold them
accountable to it um you know sometimes
you got a course correct um
you know softnecks might be necessary it
really depends on what's going on um you
know there's dishes in the sink she does
them you know if if the dishwasher is uh
you know beeped and it's and it's
finished she empties it sort of thing um
you see what i'm saying right like you
know you want a woman that's tidy
because
there's some gross chicks out there like
i'll be honest with you they live in
pigsties their cars are a total train
wreck the inside is basically a garbage
collection dump they've got a
like a freaking zoo in their house and
all these animals with hair and feces
and pee and all kinds of crap everywhere
you know what i'm talking about you want
a tidy check that cleans up unprompted
and continues to do so you know if she's
doing your laundry
and it's been going on for months and
all of a sudden she stops doing your
laundry that's a problem right hold her
accountable to it hold on a second you
know what happened over here right this
is again one of the reasons why i
invited you into my life this is why i
chose you you know let's make sure that
the stuff continues right
um we talked about losing track of time
laughter oh this is an important one
guys if you got kids or a kid
and she doesn't engage them isn't sweet
or doesn't treat them basically i mean
not like her own obviously that's
different story but if she doesn't treat
them
at least like her own nieces and nephews
okay that's a problem that's a big one
for me i got a kid if my girl doesn't
have a good relationship with her then
that's gonna be problematic on a long
term basis right that's a green flag and
you want that to continue again you know
it's the same thing with the being tidy
and cleaning up unprompted and continue
to do so sort of thing you know maintain
that relationship with
uh your kid or your kids over a long
term basis if it wavers and it gets
worse okay that that green flag turned
into a red flag you know these things
can change colors they can go back and
forth you can mention it to her and if
she doesn't acknowledge it and that's
fine you know maybe you keep at arm's
length maybe you don't invite her so
close in your life you see what i'm
saying here right you have to know how
to work these things
um we talked about social media
actually let's talk a little bit more
about social media because that's one of
the red flags i want to talk about the
green flag notion of it um she's going
to use
a smartphone a handheld device
not for attention she's going to use it
to keep in touch with family and friends
if it turns into an attention device
notifications are going off like a green
flag in a chick for me would be she
doesn't have any notifications on her
phone whatsoever
the only notification i've got on this
phone uh is phone calls and text
messages from certain people that's it
and one other message group which goes
off you know constantly if i need to
know about it but all of their
notifications from all other apps are
completely silent that's a that's a
green flag you know for me and a chick
simply because
she's not glued to that device it's not
like
you have to use
the smart smartphones
to create and make money and stay in
contact
that's really what it's for but if it's
a consumption device where you're always
on it it's binging and banging and
liking and did it and somebody said this
and dms and then
her phone's basically a box of dicks
she's going to be talking to a lot of
different dudes and i guarantee that
you're probably going to have some
problems at some point later on down the
road you know what i'm saying um she's
she she doesn't post publicly okay
um if she uses facebook there's globe
which is global for everybody to see
there's friends and then there's uh
closer networks that you can also define
as well too she's posting mostly in the
closer networks she's not posting
globally if she uses instagram it's
private it's not public if she uses it
publicly it's because she better be
selling something does she have a
makeup line does she have a service that
she performs does she have a product
line that she sells is it part of a
newsletter or something that's part of
her business you see what i'm saying
right like if she's gonna use uh social
media publicly it better be for running
a business not for any other reason
whatsoever okay green flag you
understand
um obedience obedience is important now
you should not a dog rich that's not
what i'm talking about if you ask her to
do something for the benefit of the
relationship because i'm assuming that's
what you're talking about right because
she wants to be part of your life and
you ask her to do something for the
benefit to protect it or to preserve it
or to
minimize risks and problems that might
come the way of the relationship and she
executes on your instructions that's a
good thing if she doesn't and she
protests or she puts it off or she
ignores you that is a bad thing that is
a red flag you want to identify these
green flags and make sure that you
constantly correct so you can flip back
and forth she could be green flagging
you for months and then all of a sudden
you know something comes up and you ask
her to do it she ignores you she
protests she puts it off she doesn't
acknowledge it okay now we're turning
this thing into a red flag here she's
not obedient anymore now she's a problem
for me she's liability right you have to
make sure that you're clear on these
things and that you identify the good
traits which by the way don't always
stay good okay women always reserve the
right to change their mind at any given
time
any place anywhere
she could have
you know
she could have a affinity for doing your
laundry and then it stops and you're
like
what happened there i thought that this
is something that was going to continue
right and then you try to encourage the
same behavior that existed before
doesn't okay i'm not as keen on that
anymore right these are you know these
are some of the things that i
took into consideration when i decided
to invite you into my life you see what
i'm saying
so obedience is one of those things and
i think it's really important to
understand because you want a woman
that's a compliment to your life not the
focus and if she's constantly dragging
your attention away from things that
your attention should not be dragged
away from because of trivial
drama
disobedience whatever it happens to be
that's problematic that's a red flag
look for the green flags and ladies if
you're watching this
all these i mean
all women out there they want the exact
same thing six six six six foot tall six
inches in the pants six-figure income
six months out of a relationship 600
horsepower car blah blah it keeps going
down the list right funny competent
alpha uh
you know i can keep going right all of
these things you want all those things
out of a guy well guess what what do you
bring to the table are you bringing
problems into a man's life or are you
bringing solutions are you a compliment
to his life are you useful are you you
know when he asks you to do something
are you complying are you obedient or do
you protest and you know behave like a
little brat you see what i'm saying here
these green flags and red flags are
things that i talk about for a reason
because guys need to understand them
and women if you're listening to this
you need to understand that a guy in
that position has the right to do all of
these things if you don't like that you
go find the dorky beta out there and you
can be with that because that's all
you're going to get top shelf men don't
put up with crap that's just the way
that it is
just have a quick look over here and see
what we got going on in the chat oh you
guys are tearing it up moth got jaren in
there from menshrine a bunch of you guys
are ripping it up got a couple super
chats here yes looks like we have an
agreement just supporting the content
thank you appreciate that diamond
what is up
that is the uh the bulk of the list i
didn't talk about the competing part
um
it's a red flag on my list again it's on
this chapter if you want to grab it but
you do not want a woman that competes
with what you're doing
um
let's say
you know like as an example so i have a
youtube channel and i help guys unplug
from comforting lies and you know fix
their lives sort of thing
let's say that she's doing something
that competes with that or you know uh
causes problems for that narrative right
that's a problem that's not a green flag
that's a red flag on the other hand if
she's like you know telling a dude hey
you know
my boyfriend got this book it's a nice
piece of work you should check it out
it'll solve your
issues in your head you see what i'm
saying right like you want the woman to
compliment your life you're looking for
a green flag so
i'm not really sure why it's not that
obvious to some guys out there
um i've spelled out a few of these
things from a number of different
perspectives from my own from a few
other guys that i've spoken with but you
want
yeah so
jiren's in a chat that's a great point
the way they put it there only take
women that collaborate with you not
compete right you want a woman that's
going to collaborate with what you're
doing what can i do to be useful you
know would be you know if a woman can
come up to me and say hey rich what can
i do to be useful to you today with what
whatever project that you're working on
that's a green flag you're not going to
get that though very often very very
very few women you know will set aside
what it is that's going on in their
world and their phone for a few moments
just to say hey rich you know what can i
do to be useful to you today in your
this or that or whatever you see what
i'm saying
right
you want her to be a compliment
um lena says what about easily threaten
lots are
um
threatened by what you know threatened
by
um
[Music]
what exactly like other women
like some competition anxiety is good
when it comes to women so i think that
she should recognize your value and
recognize that other women are going to
be interested in you because of your
value that's fine but if it turns into
something like extreme jealousy which i
talk about in the red flag chapter below
you'll see what the difference is right
competition
competition anxiety is totally fine
absolutely fine there's nothing wrong
with that
you